what is going on everybody welcome to
part 2 of the SFTP with python tutorial
video in this video we're going to be
discussing how to actually put a file up
on your server using Python so the first
thing that we're going to do is import
PI SFTP as just SFTP and that's the only
thing we have to import actually and
that's pretty much it for the rest of
this video series and so you guys
probably what the heck my name is
download param Iko and PI crypto well
we're amiko is a dependency of pious FTP
and PI crypto is a dependency of param
eco so they're all kind of bundled into
this single import pretty much so the
next thing we want to do is let's go
ahead define our function and it's going
to define SFTP example and I always like
to put everything in a nice sexy try and
set loop here so branch from E and what
we're going to be trying is we're going
to first establish our connection so the
first thing we're going to do is say s
equals SFTP dot connection with a
capital C and in here you've got three
parameters host username and password
and you can also put a port in there but
for SFTP you're not going to really need
the port for if you were connecting via
SSH you would need the port which is
most likely to be 22 but you can find
out also on your server but we're not
doing SSH we're doing SFTP host equals
and this would be the IP address to your
website or your actual website address
so like for me we're going to be doing
this with my H Kinsley website so H
Kinsley comm will be those but there's
also an IP address that you can could
connect to as well the next parameter is
going to be a username and I'm going to
leave this just kind of empty I'll put
user in there just for something I'm not
going to fill those in on video and
password equals pass and so anyway
whatever your username and password
or that's what you want to put in there
if you don't even know like if you have
a SSH let's say well if FTP is installed
after like on most VPS is it'll give you
like your root username password or
it'll give you the same SSH user names
and passwords but it kind of depends on
your installation of FTP some-some
almost VPS is Arnie we're going to come
with FTP installed like you'll have to
install that yourself so if you have no
idea you might want to find out if you
even have FTP and then finally any like
most I've never seen like a web hosting
company that didn't have a like a legit
when I guess like I don't know like for
emotion I don't think they come with
like FTP but you know like GoDaddy and
Hostgator and all these kind of
companies they all have FTP already
installed so if you have like something
like that you can use this whereas like
sometimes they don't have SSH
capabilities for you so or they just
don't allow SSH anyway make sure you've
got FTP installed in a few minutes I'll
be talking about another issue with FTP
usually if if you're on a VPS but we'll
get to that in a minute so we've done
that we're going to want to say a remote
path and this will be where is the file
going to go right and for this you have
to give that full path so in our case
it'll be var don't forget that first /ww
HTML and then we're going to want to
just put it at the example dot txt so so
this example file will be at H Kingsley
com slash example dot txt now the next
thing we want to specify is the local
path so where it is this a file and let
me just bring up that file for you guys
let's see here here we go so this is the
file here that we're going to put up
when we bring it up and it just says
whoa examples are awesome and so that's
our file and it's located on desktops
and txt lessons as this age even though
this is not an SSH tutorial anyway um
so the local path is C colon slash
actually the script is in the same
directory so I'm just going to do a nice
sexy example that text like that you
could also give the full path but always
check your remote and does the other
thing is example dot text and in fact
let's call it my knowledge live example
I guess that's unlikely to roll over
something but keep in mind that this
will rewrite anything that you put there
right so I got most FTP stuff like if
you click and drag something in there
and it's already like a file exists with
that name it's going to be like are you
sure you want to do that whereas here
there's going to be no are you sure if
you're used to like running commands on
like SSH and stuff there's very few like
fail safes for idiots so so be really
careful
make sure you really check this full
HTML path make sure you didn't you know
try to create a new directory or put a
file in here that you should never have
put it cetera so once you've done that
the next thing that more I'm gonna do is
f dot put and from here you specify the
logo path remote pad easy easy easy
finally the last thing you want to do
just like when you open files you don't
want to close that connection so you
close that connection now go up here
like this make this a nice pretty
looking script SFTP example run it right
so make sure you filled in all this
stuff what I'm going to go ahead and do
is let's see here and make sure it looks
good
I'm going to put this stuff way down
here so I can run it and I'm going to
edit my information into here and then
we'll we'll see how it works all right
so let's run this and figure out what
typos we've made so save it yep run it
let me drag this over real quick and as
long as it said nothing I guess
then you succeeded if you got an error
then you have not succeeded so just to
make sure let's go ahead and test and
see if we did indeed succeed here so let
me bring over a town and chopped H
Kingsley here and we'll bring over this
sexy mug here HQ sitcom / example dot
txt sure enough there's our file on the
server done completely with this awesome
Python spirit oops
end up full screen so now that that's
done let me close out of this and it's
talked about some of the errors that you
might have received um probably the most
popular error is this bad authentication
err so let me just make I'll just make
some comments here and use this is a bit
of a notepad here the Mike a little bit
now so you might get this error that you
know basically off then too bad
authentication here and this could be
either you have an incorrect password or
your server is not allowing password
authentication so some hosting companies
are going to do this in the name of
security or they're going to suggest to
you that you do it the name of security
when you are creating your server and it
might just be in the form of like a
check box and then they do it or you
might actually run the command and just
forgotten but regardless sometimes it's
not allowed to connect via just simply a
username and password because like kind
of the idea of SSH is that not only if
you have a username password but you
also have an encrypted key right well
not mean card to key you have a key
though and so not only would they need
the username passed
they'd also need a key but I've never
liked and the idea is so they can't
connect by a SSA it's right but I've
never really had a hosting company that
did not that one allowed FTP or SSH and
two did not um not allow a either file
transfer not like all you needed to do
is log into the hosting company website
or even better an SSH client that all
you needed was to logging the hosting
company website so I don't really see
the huge issue here unless you're
running a web server off of your own um
your own server right so if you follow
maybe my Raspberry Pi web server
tutorial that might be a scenario where
it makes sense and it really would be
added security to not allow password
authentication but anyway if you're
getting this error and you're positive
that your user name and password are
correct then what you're gonna want to
do is an also missionary of FTP actually
installed on your server but um the next
thing that you're going to need to do is
modify and or possibly uncomment the
password authentication variable in the
following so open up SSH into your you
know sudo nano I guess I could type it
out Pluto et Cie SSH SSH D underscore
config and you'll open that up and then
you'll kind of scroll down on its like
halfway through the file and there's a
variable that is password authentication
and it's either going to be like you
know it'll be like this password
authentication yes it'll be like
commented out and then the other one
will be password authentication no or
you can just delete the current one and
put just yes or delete no and put yes
whatever just make sure the password
authentication variable says yes and
it's not following a pound sign you know
so make sure it looks
that pound sign is commented out so
that's that and if you also if you want
to use a key you can also run the SSH
key generator on urghhh ssh-keygen so it
is oops
SSH you on that command right on your
local machine and that'll generate that
a proper like RSA I'll go key but again
I'm not really going to cover that in
these videos param Eco has some really
really cool stuff that you can do with
SSH so so if you wanted to use para miko
and you want that key generated and then
because like also paramiku is going to
allow you to run you know ssh commands
because param eCos SSH what we're
dealing with right here is just paya
there is just SFTP secure fired File
Transfer Protocol so it's going to
conclude putting the file up to the
server in the next video we're going to
be talking about how to get a file from
the server so with that thanks for
watching thanks for all the support the
subscriptions and until next time